- On this episode, it got so crazy,
I decided to make a
t-shirt about episode 158.
(hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions
and I answer them.
This is the #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 158
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
It is a Halloween edition, I guess.
Steve and I decided to dress.
Casper, at least India
brought a little thunder
for Halloween, and we have a pumpkin.
We've got pumpkins.
- [Steve] Gotta count for something.
- Gotta count for something.
It is also Friday, which means
I give my official prediction
and truth be told, I've been very hectic.
I was in Buffalo for two days.
Big shout out to Buffalo,
had a great time up there
for the 43 North startup competition.
Great company received a
million dollars last night.
It was kinda crazy,
actually, to think about it.
Um, got to co-judge with
a bunch of great people
including my good friend Mike Lazerow,
founder of Buddy Media.
So it was a lot of fun for me.
Love you Laz, if you're watchin' this.
And so, uh, that's it, and uh,
where I was going with that was
I actually don't know what my prediction
for the Jets-Raiders game is going to be.
For all of you, I knew everybody's
betting heavy this week
given that I am six-for-six.
So, I wanna give that
little bit of context
because I think I've thought
through everything else
in the past.
It's gonna be a challenging game.
I'm going to Oakland for the game.
Tough place to be a visiting fan,
so India knows that.
India, wait a minute, is
this a little bit of a
Raiders outfit
- [India] Yeah.
- [Gary] that you're wearing?
- A little bit, accidentally,
- [Gary] Was this.
- [India] But.
- [India] I was raised a
Raider's fan, actually.
- But lately you've been finding yourself
intrigued by the Jets stuff.
- It's true, I just like,
don't own a lot of green.
But I do have a dope
Jets jacket.
- [Gary] You don't wear,
you don't wear a lot of green?
- I don't wear a lot of colors.
- I haven't noticed.
(laughter)
India, let's get into,
- The show!
- The show.
- (together) The show.
- [Gary] Show.
- [India] You love doing that.
- [Gary] Yeah, I think it's really neat.
I do think it's neat.
(laughter)
I like neat, neat-o, neat-o.
- [India] Green?
- I don't know, I'm just
curious what's happening.
I haven't seen that maneuver in the past.
- [DRock] A hundred
and, that makes sense.
Go ahead.
- What happened?
I like knowing.
- [DRock] I just
had one quit a little,
now we're focused on this.
- Oh you just deleted it?
In case it went?
- [DRock] Mmhmm.
So was it rolling the whole time?
- [DRock] No.
- So there was a cut.
- [DRock] Correct.
- You're going to show this part,
of my anger at the cut, right?
'Cause I want everybody to understand
how angry I am with cuts.
- [DRock] We always have
to cut when she asks questions.
- Oh, interesting.
All right.
Still show this, DRock.
I will be double checking.
- [Voiceover] Anthony asks,
"Is it wise to form a startup
around an app or website
"which will solve a problem,
but without yet knowing
"how to monetize it?"
- Yes, Anthony.
Solving problems in utility form
is one of the greatest ways
to make a shitload of money.
You know, for, I mean like, absolutely.
Like, like, if you, you know, yes.
I'm like, anytime you solve things for,
anytime you solve things for people,
monetizing becomes the
easiest part of the equation.
The reason I'm pausing a
little and jumping around,
Vayner Nation, is I'm
rolling with disrespect
for Anthony, 'cause.
It's Anthony?
- [India] Mmhmm.
Because it's, it only
speaks to me not believing
that you're gonna solve the problem,
to be very honest with you.
It, it like, I have a bad
feeling in my stomach.
Anthony, I love you, thank
you for supporting the show.
I have no interest in dropping venom
on Halloween here, but, um.
Yes, that's so like crazy to think about.
There's a million ways to monetize.
If you actually bring value to people,
even if you make people laugh
and escape their real life,
you make tons of money.
It's called the entire
entertainment business.
Right?
Like, if you solve something tangible,
like invent a car so we
don't have to take horses,
ya sell it.
Like if you make something, sell something
that's a thing that makes thing better,
you monetize by charging
for something that,
I'm just.
I don't even wanna answer
this question.
- [India] Sorry.
This is crazy question.
- [India] I'm sorry.
- Again, the last part,
even if you don't know
how you're gonna monetize it yet?
- [India] If you don't know yet know
how you're going to monetize it.
- You're gonna sell it!
You're gonna sell it.
You've solved a problem,
you're gonna sell it!
Either to a human, or
to a business that wants
to sponsor the fact that we've
solved somebody's problem,
which is the height of value in humanity.
- [India] Mmhmm.
- Oh look, I created this potion
that makes people feel better.
How am I ever gonna make money?
I mean, what the (bleep).
I mean seriously, people.
We've done this for 158 shows.
Like, seriously.
Ah!
I wanna, I feel like I might,
the reason I'm asking
again is not for show,
it's because I'm trying to
make sure I didn't just,
you know sometimes I jump to, you know.
You know how you guys always talk about me
cutting people off in like key notes,
it's 'cause I already know what's coming?
Sometimes I do that so,
- [India] No I think --
- What's the question one more time?
- [India] You got it.
Is it wise to form a startup
around an app slash website
which will solve a problem --
- Yeah, forget it.
I heard it what I needed to.
Go ahead.
- [India] I think you're good.
- Jesus Christ!
(laughter)
Scarin' the crap outta me.
Who is it?
Let me take my butt,
yeah don't get.
Yeah, well that's what you get,
if you come in my show,
I'm gonna squeeze your ass.
Alright, let's go.
(laughter)
- [Steve] God dammit, Gary.
- Listen, I'm in a weird mood.
I'm pissed about that first question.
And I mean it was a dude.
You know, that's a big part of it, Steve.
So don't get scared.
- [India] Okay.
Maybe I should go to a different question.
- No, go to Cliff.
Why, you worried about this one too?
- [India] No, I'm just like worried
that maybe you'll be angry
just 'cause you're angry.
All right.
I noticed that you endorsed certain --
- And who was that just came in
to do that and dropped candies
of competitors of VaynerMedia clients?
Who's that?
Yeah, we're gonna find out.
- [Steve] It was Kelly.
- Is that Kelly?
He's dead.
Come with me, DRock.
Hey, Kelly.
Kelly!
- [India] Kelly!
- [Gary] Kelly, lemme
ask you a funny question.
Since you just started to disrupt my show.
Did you come on my show
and literally drop candy
on my table from a competitor to clients
of VaynerMedia that sell candy?
(mumbles indistinctly)
- Yeah, okay.
Yeah, you're lucky you can't talk.
You're real lucky.
'Cause that's ludicrous, Andy.
Thank you, Steve.
Yeah, episode 158.
One for the record books.
Cliff?
- Cliff asks,
"I noticed that you endorse certain books
"and allow yourself to
be quoted on the cover.
"I thought you didn't read books?"
- Over the last year, I have
given two or three quotes
to books, which is highly
unusual, I see Steve about it,
and Steve's always cynical, look,
he already dissed me in the show,
like, you know.
You said, "Oh, Gary."
You know, but I had to
explain myself to you.
(laughter)
Um, uh, so I rarely do it.
Steve's shaking his head because he sees
the millions that come through, requests.
And we always say no,
'cause I don't read them,
and how am I gonna put my name on it.
The only reason I've put my name
on a couple of books, is
because I know the human being.
And so, that's what uh, that's what.
As I've gotten to know Jay Bear,
and others of that nature.
Actually, that one's not even out yet,
so Louis, you know.
These are people I know,
I feel comfortable with.
And if you actually
look carefully, at the,
and Steve knows this because he helps me
edit some of these quotes sometimes,
I won't say things more
specific about the book.
I'll say, "Jay has a
great read on the market."
So I've very careful with saying,
"In this book, he will
change your, on page 147,"
you know?
It's very Jay.
And so as I've gotten to know people
over the last seven to 10 years,
and I feel like I've gotten to know them,
I've felt comfortable
to give them something.
These are friends of mine who are trying
to leverage my name to do something
that's important to them,
and I've been careful
with the way I've positioned the quote.
You know, to make it more about them.
And so that's it, I'm
really glad you asked
that question, India,
'cause it's the right.
I saw it and I was like,
even I was a little
too scared to send it to you
and say I should answer this.
So, but it's the right thing to do,
to answer these questions.
That's why we have the show,
not just to pick the easy ones.
I like that you do that.
Keep doin' it.
You know what, by the way?
Go harder.
LIke, luckily lately,
because I think the show
has painted a better
360-version of myself,
people are dissing on me less,
because I think the depth has been able
to be sucked out, and so,
but I'm always happy to
answer the toughest of tough.
- [India] Wanna do a hater episode?
- I mean I don't know if I wanna,
yeah, let's do a hater episode.
We'll call it the hater-ade episode.
I'm thrilled to answer, actually,
I love answering those questions.
- [India] Okay.
- Yeah.
Somebody hated on me on Facebook,
and I saw somebody come in and say,
"Obviously you're not watching the show."
Because there was like, some sort of thing
about non-details, so.
What are you lookin' at?
You're just trying to make, you're look.
- [India] I saw Ty coming in.
- You were just wondering
what he dressed up as?
- [India] Yeah, but I'm
disappointed 'cause --
- Dressed up as a loser.
(laughter)
Good costume.
- [India] Um, from Kamil.
- Kamil.
- Kamil asks,
"How would you market
an HR staffing agency?"
- Um, Kamil I would market
an HR staffing agency
by creating enormous amounts of content.
I would probably reach out to the biggest
HR software companies in the world
to see if they had a
blog, and then email them
and say that you would
love to write guest blogs
around HR dynamics in organizations.
I think that would be
incredible way to do it.
I think guest blogging
is a stunning arbitrage
that most people don't take advantage of.
If you are starting any
business right now of any,
a landscaping business, a
chocolate making business,
a candle selling business,
you go map the 15 sites
that most of the people that
are likely to buy your product
are spending their time reading,
and reach out to the editors and ask them
to guest blog, whether an audio form,
video form, or written form,
depending on your skills sets.
They may be a written blog,
you can't write like me,
and they won't take video or audio,
then you're going to miss
out on the opportunity.
But maybe you find two or three,
being able to siphon that
attention to awareness
around you, as long as you
don't make your article
about you selling stuff.
You have to level up
and be a media company.
So for you, what's the name again, Kamil?
- [India] Kamil.
- Kamil, what you need to do is talk
about six behaviors you look for
in an employee that's
been in your organization
for three years, and
then you write about it,
instead of saying,
why using a staffing
agency is a good idea.
Can't be in your best interests,
it has to be in the
audience's best interests.
Hence this show.
This show is to bring
as much value as it can
to build up equity, to bring up value,
to bring up leverage.
To guilt everybody who watches
and listens to this show
to buying many, many books
of the #AskGaryVee show.
Or tell people to watch it.
That leads to speaking engagements
or clients of VaynerMedia.
Or, what I really care about,
'cause those last three things
are nice-to-haves, turn
everybody in the world
into a New York Jets fan when I own them.
So, you know, I think that um.
By the way, you know what's
gonna be funny about that?
I'm literally gonna clip that in 30 years,
and I'm gonna play it in the stadium.
Just want you to know.
Um, so, I would do that.
I would start putting out infographic
or visuals in Instagram,
and use the right hashtags
for discovery around HR.
That may sound very weird.
It's probably very, very, very niche,
but there are tons of
HR people on Instagram.
I mean, we have a HR department,
they're all on Instagram.
So there's a lot of hacks,
but it's all about content.
Level yourself up and
act like a media company
instead of an agency.
Put out content.
That's what we do for VaynerMedia.
I, at the forefront, am great
at it, and that's just truth.
I mean, I'm sorry, but it's true.
I'm great at producing content.
My team's great at helping.
You know, that has been
a huge gateway drug
to new business and building
the brand of VaynerMedia.
Then you have to deliver.
Because what comes along with it,
especially when your a personal brand
that is charismatic, as
good looking as I am,
is there's a level of cynicism
that comes along with that.
So a lot of our early clients were like,
"Eh, is this Gary Vee with a
buncha bullshit behind him?"
So then you gotta deliver too.
So there's a lot of things you have to do
to be good at business.
You have to bring 'em to the table,
and then you gotta serve 'em great food.
And then, they come
back to your restaurant.
Get it?
You like that?
- [India] Yeah.
- Yeah, you can't just get
'em to the restaurant, India.
Steve, you can't just
get 'em to your place.
- No.
- When they eat the porridge,
it's gotta taste good.
- Are we serving porridge?
- Yeah, we're gonna start
a porridge restaurant.
The three of us.
- [Steve] Very Belarusian I would imagine.
- What's that?
- That's so trendy I bet now, porridge.
- You know what?
I bet you porridge is not trendy,
but it could be, I bet you if we --
- [India] Well, yeah.
- If we opened a porridge restaurant --
- [India] Yeah, oh yeah.
- in Williamsburg, we will dominate.
Guys I'm not joking right now.
Do you wanna do it?
- [Steve] Tons of reclaimed wood.
- [India] Yes!
- Wait, okay.
Hold on, let's do something crazy as shit.
Right now, right now.
Right now on the #AskGaryVee Show,
do we wanna do a porridge popup
for one week in December?
From today, which is almost.
- [India] Yes.
- Can we get the Vayner
Nation, who can make porridge?
We can use storefront
to find the location.
I'm gonna be busy, so
it's really on you guys.
I'm just --
- [Steve] Reservations
exclusively through Resy?
- Reservations through Resy,
oh Resy's not here anymore.
Resy had to move, they're gettin' bigger.
Uh, a porridge popup.
- [India] Love it, I love it.
- [Gary] December 14 to.
- No, no.
You love it, Steve's
worried because he knows
he has to put in the work.
I see you're scared of the work.
- [Steve] That's a lot of bandwidth.
- [India] I have people who could help us.
- All right, well, let's see
what happens in the comments.
India, you take a look.
Let's see how much assets we
might of randomly on the spot.
I'm telling you, is this 158?
- [India] 158.
- And, you guys since we're so far.
- [DRock] Andy's around the corner.
- Is that Staphon?
I thought he was sick!
Good job.
I, is there any?
Oh, not Andy, I need Andrew.
(laughter)
Uh, I think we're gonna need
a t-shirt for episode 158.
This is gonna go down big time.
Porridge pop up.
- [India] I just think it's cute.
- Yeah, of course, it's porridge pop up.
- [Steve] No, but we'd have to call it
something like 415 Bedford.
It would just have porridge.
- No, call it porridge pop up.
(laughter)
- [India] Okay, from Scott.
- [Voiceover] Scott asks,
"Can you build a strong
social media following
"solely by engaging with your audience
"or is content an absolute must?"
- Content is an absolute
must, interesting.
(laughter)
Listen, I mean, I think you
could build up something
really, really interesting by
being a full-pledge listener.
You know, it depends on
how you define content,
which is why I kind of wavered off.
If you're listening, you're gonna respond.
Your responses are your content.
So, if you're asking me,
"Can you just search,
"engage with conversations
and put out those answers?"
I would argue that that's what I did do
in 2006, seven, and eight.
Outside of me just putting a link
to the Wine Library TV show,
which is a pretty big piece of content,
so I can't really go there, so.
Look, I would you I've
disproportionately gotten value
from my engagement, but
I think historically,
I've underminded, or even
slightly disrespected my content.
I've changed over the
last three to four years
on that point of view.
I realized the content did matter.
I think it's a really
interesting question.
But I think your answers are your content.
I mean, very honestly, I
think that's why my brand
in the business world
and entrepreneur land
and startup land has gotten stronger,
because I think I've positioned myself
to actually use my
responses as my content.
We are literally, this is
literally a very meta-answer.
We are in the context of a show
that is predicated on me giving answers
and engaging versus me
self-starting around the content.
But then, that in itself is
the depth of the content.
So I think it depends
on how far you take it,
in the, you know, semantically,
I would say, yes you can.
Because I think you can put a lot of depth
and a lot of oomph and a lot of weight,
you know, this is heavy,
and a lot of weight.
Um, you know what Mike makes me do?
This crap.
It's the worst.
Um, uh, yes, because I think
you can put a lot of oomph
behind the content in response.
I call it counter-punching.
I would argue that Floyd Mayweather
is gonna go down as this
generation's best boxer
completely predicated on your answer,
so take that for what it is.
Why Floyd Mayweather is
great at content marketing.
You know?
- [Steve] We wrote that article.
- I know.
- [India] From Josh.
- Josh.
- [India] It just says Josh.
- I'm gonna bet it's Joshua.
- [India] Well, probably.
- Do you think his mom calls him Joshua?
- [India] Yes.
- Me too.
Go 'head.
- Josh asks,
"Is there question you wish people
"would stop asking you?"
- Joshua, it's that question.
Um, well the first one
got my panties in a bunch.
- [India] Yeah, that's true.
- Um, no not really, man.
To be honest with you,
I'm too overwhelmed with
gratitude and flattered
that people want to ask me questions,
that it's hard for me to
get going around the notion
of judging those questions.
These are questions that,
everybody's in a different life cycle
in their careers and lives
to where they think I could bring value,
whether they're a parent
with an entrepreneurial kid,
whether they're an entrepreneur
and just realized it,
whether they've always
been an entrepreneur
and can really associate
with my immigrant and selling hustle,
I think everybody's in a different place
when they come across my content.
Since so many people are
discovering it these days,
'cause there's a lot of
virality going on on Facebook.
As a matter of fact, you know what?
This is a good opportunity,
I put in the comments
with the Share Monster?
I really, really would love
some support on Facebook.
I mean look, I'm selfish
like anybody else.
I'm enjoying the discovery
of all these new audiences.
Everybody who's sharing for me,
and there's a consistent crew
that I wanna give so much love to,
everybody that's sharing, I
really, really appreciate it.
And if you're listening
or watching right now,
if you're listening,
literally pull over your car
on the highway in traffic,
take out your phone,
go to the episode on Facebook
and hit the share button.
And by the way, if you did that,
you are the most amazing
person of all time.
But if you're watching on Facebook,
or a lot of you I know
are watching on YouTube,
coming over to Facebook,
that would mean something.
I would love to see, I'm curious
where this call to action,
where this right hook
lands me in the share lexicon
for my normal average.
That being said, no, that's
it, that's the answer.
I have high empathy for everybody
being in a different place
in their mind at the moment
where they feel compelled
to ask me a question,
and the only emotions in
my body are gratitude.
- [India] Told you.
- That's the show.
- [India] I have a question.
- [Gary] You have a question.
- Mmhmm.
- What is go, this is a crazy episode.
Why don't you come up with a question too,
while we're at it?
And you know what, go hard
at it.
- [India] Nikki's costume's
is so good!
- Oh Nik, very good.
Very --
- [Steve] What the --
- Very, very good.
- [India] It's silly, but I
- [Gary] Very good.
- [India] just love Halloween.
- [Gary] What the hell?
- [India] I know, right.
(laughter)
- [Gary] That is amazing.
Hey, Sky.
So good!
What is going on in episode 158?
- It's Halloween!
- Jeez!
All right.
- [Voiceover] India asks.
- Your favorite costume you ever had
as a kid, that you were just like
pumped to go out and wear
and you felt so proud and excited.
- That's a great question.
I'm gonna go with when me and my sister
dressed up as Tom and Jerry.
- Nice.
- You know what's interesting,
this is a great opportunity.
I never talk about the year
that we lived in Dover, New Jersey.
Do you know that?
- I did not know that.
- Right.
None of you know this.
It went, I always say Queens to Edison,
but the truth is, I don't even know why,
I just forget about that
year and a half in Dover.
Maybe because I don't like it.
Maybe the reason I love the Jets so much
is that the kids were nice to me
and we played football, and they wanted
to be Jet fans and in Dover.
Do you, one of you have heard this story
where the kid made me drink
pee out of a Pepsi can?
- Yup, we have heard that story.
- You've heard it right?
Steve you didn't hear it?
- [Steve] I feel like, I don't know,
I've blocked it out.
- [Gary] Yeah!
- [Gary] Yeah, I got picked on quite a bit
'cause I didn't speak English yet.
I was little.
And so, and so um
my sister and I dressed
up as Tom and Jerry,
and my mom likes to tell the story that,
my sister was still in a
carriage, she was young.
I would go up stairs, knock
on the door, get the candy,
and then I would always
get candy for my sister.
'Cause I'd be like, my
sister's down below.
It's just the story means a lot to me
about the relationship that
I have with my sister Liz,
and so um, that's the costume
that always sticks in my mind.
- Nice.
- Yeah.
- It's a good costume.
- Thanks.
Steve?
Not as sweet, go sour on me.
Go 'head.
- [Voiceover] Stunwin asks.
- So.
- Actually I'm scared.
- Ready?
- Yeah.
- So VaynerMedia has always been in like,
turbo growth mode.
- [Gary] Aw, crap.
- [Gary] Yes.
- Right, like always.
It's always bring on more clients,
hire more people, run out of space,
rinse and repeat, right?
- Yes.
- Do you think there will ever be a time
where VaynerMedia prioritizes
depth over width
in terms of charging more, you know,
bigger, fatter --
- Scopes?
- scopes, and --
- Subjective call on the
quality of the output?
- Right, or, but then that
laddering up to sort of...
- A plateauing of people?
- Turning into like big,
huge, lavish benefit packages
and things like some agencies get
really, really, really
crazy with that, right?
Where we're scrappier, right?
- Yup.
- And I'm not saying that's the point --
- No, no, no, you're not.
- But do you think Vayner will ever
slow down --
- [Gary] You mean like,
paying people 200 thousand dollar bonues
to be the best creative director
in the world kinda thing?
- Well, yeah sure, I guess.
- I mean, I'm just, I wanna
quantify that part of it.
- Right, exactly.
So it's like depth over
width in terms of like,
sheer dollar amounts as
they relate to clients,
employees, benefits, all that stuff.
And I'm not saying it's bad right now,
by any stretch, right?
- Yeah, no.
I'm not worried about that.
So I think, for me,
the way I run my business, which is why
I think I'm running a much better business
than all these other
agencies that do that,
is because I think you can
achieve both in parallel.
So I think what I uniquely
as an entrepreneur
am good at, is running both trains.
So I think you could easily, as,
in the context of your question,
speak to a very different level of quality
in the building from 18 months ago.
- Right.
- So, if you just project out,
if you think about the fact that
we didn't have a single SVP
or real creative director
like of any, real's not fair.
A creative director of 10
years or more experience
just 18 months ago.
- Mmhmm.
- That you can see that
happening in parallel.
I think that, I think
where it gets disguised is
we have people that come
from Gray and Ogilvy
and things of that nature.
We also have, what's
been very happy to me,
to see Aton and Harry and Pensoot
and all these people
leveling up in parallel.
What it gets disguised by is the thing
that's much more obvious.
What's much more obvious is
hyper growth of people, right?
- Yeah.
- It's just, getting
crammed when we grow, right?
What's less obvious is,
you know, anyone's ability
to really truly dissect 550
people's depth of skill.
- Yeah.
- And there's pockets of clients.
You're always gonna have
variable depending on the people.
Plus, hiring the right people.
So, to me, the answer is,
it's happening in parallel.
I think the only thing that makes people
think that it's happening,
is stop the hiring process
and then they're like, "Oh!
"We're not going hyper,
we're going deeper."
- Yeah.
- I think we've gone stunningly deep
in 18 months by two variables.
One, bringing the outside
talent in their 30s and 40s,
right, depth, which is gray hairs.
in a lot of people's
subjective point of view.
And number two, the actual growth
of the people that have been at Vayner
that are totally different animals.
And I think that, for every
individual it's different.
And I also think that for the people
that have been here longer,
it's a different context point
than it is for other people.
You know, and so, no I mean, I think
as long as I'm running the business,
I'm never comfortable in thinking
one has to be done without the other.
I truly feel that you're
capable to do both.
And I think if you project
out what's happened
in the last 18 months on the depth chart,
that it's actually tremendously scalable
and gets way deeper
because as you get bigger,
you deploy those dollars to those things.
- Mmhmm.
- And as far as like, benefits
and packages, you know.
I'm very weird when it comes to bonuses.
I think bonuses, so we've
hired two people recently
that left their agencies
because of bonuses.
Because they felt they deserved more.
I think when you have a graying zone of,
I get to be the judge
and jury on the bonus,
I think what is safer
is to just try to get
to a number together.
And I think that those
things ebb and flow.
I also think that when you're
in a fast-growing company,
what a lot of employees don't calibrate,
'cause they shouldn't,
'cause it's very hard
for anybody to care about anything
besides what they care
about for themselves,
is the notion of what happens
in a 36-month window
versus a 12-month window.
So I've been happy to be honest with you,
of getting three to four
emails in the last six months
from former employees
who left because of money
who now make less money than some
of their counterparts here
because VaynerMedia is growing,
and we've been able to rise all ships,
and in their other places they haven't.
And so, those are my answers.
- Bonus question.
- Please.
- How fast do you think
we max out the space
at Hudson Yards?
- I think we might of already.
- Nice.
I think, you know, I do think that
every company has to bear the negatives
that come along with the positives
for their individual
self around the person
that runs the company.
I love insanity.
(laughter)
I like it.
I like when we're like this.
I like when we're sitting
this close to each other.
I like it.
And if you are not that,
if you're somebody that really like that,
and your space, and this
is where I put this,
and this is where I put this,
then, you know, Vayner
can be tricky at times.
Though, no question, I
think it's a leader's job
to adjust to his reality,
and I've definitely
deployed more empathy towards the way
we plan on scaling Hudson Yards,
and if we need secondary offices to try
to come back a little bit
on my own selfish love
of that kinetic energy.
Mainly predicated on, because
the floors are so big.
So I think I'm gonna be
able to scratch my itch,
'cause they're just big floor plates
and there'll be three, four
hundred people comfortably
on one floor.
And so I'm hoping that
solves that problem.
So, thanks Steve.
All right, that's all been one,
this whole episode's been
one big, kind of like,
trying to stretch it
out as long as possible
so I can really figure
out, what was happening
in my other parallel
mind, during this show,
just like I run businesses, in parallel.
In my other parallel mind, which is like,
what is really gonna happen on Sunday
between the Jets and the Raiders?
You know, I can't lie, I
was affected last night
by the Patriots dismantling the Dolphins.
And me projecting then
just to four days earlier
the Jets hung in there pretty tight.
I've been really worried about this.
I think the Raiders
have the kind of offense
that could pose a little
bit of trouble for the Jets.
I also thought the Jets played
particularly well last week.
And I do think Oakland is a
very difficult place to play.
They're coming off a huge
win against the Chargers,
a rival of theirs on the road.
That place is gonna be
rowdy and uncomfortable.
Though the Jets have
shown enormous composure
this year with Todd Bowles at the helm
and have swung me.
I've been picking the
Raiders in my head all week
right up to this point,
and in the moment of truth,
in the moment of truth, I'm
gonna go 25-24 New York Jets
in an absolute nail biter, nervous scary.
(shudders and buzzes)
25-24 New York Jets.
You keep asking questions.
I went for a dramatic pause.
I'll keep answering them.
Happy Halloween, everybody.
Enjoy it, especially
if you're lucky enough,
like I am to have the kiddos.
It's fun.
(hip hop music)